après les excuses bidons des personnes
arrêtées sans leur autorisation on va
vous révéler aujourd'hui les
verbalisations les plus insolites du
confinement en france et à l'étranger et
vous allez voir que l'amande peut être
très salée
regardez petit récap rester enfermé
toute la journée sans pouvoir quitter
son domicile peut rendre aussi et
certains ont décidé de céder à la
tentation de l'extérieur malgré les
interdictions formelle du gouvernement
depuis plusieurs semaines toutes les
excuses semblent bonnes pour aller
prendre l'air si certains sortent leurs
chiens nous soit par jour d'autres
restent toute la journée au supermarché
quand les derniers ont décidé de se
mettre subitement au footing
après 10 ans d'inaction mais certains
sont plus inventifs que d'autres en
italie une sexagénaire de la région de
rome s'est fait interpeller par la
police alors qu'elle se promenait dans
la rue quand les forces de l'ordre lui
ont demandé la raison de sa sortie la
femme a répondu que sa tortue domestique
avait besoin de prendre l'air à
marseille un habitant a quant à lui
imaginé que comme il n'avait pas de
chien il avait le droit de sortir son
animal un boa qu'il portait autour du
cou plus fou encore à plouigneau dans le
finistère un habitant n'a même pas fait
l'effort de sortir avec un véritable
animal dans la rue il s'est rendu dans
un parc avec son téléphone portable dans
le but d'en attraper un en effet ce
jeune homme jouer à pokémon godon
l'optique d'agrandir sa team de pokémon
dans le doubs des gendarmes ont contrôlé
une voiture suspects et qui semble s
agiter en s'approchant ils ont découvert
un couple qui s'en donnent visiblement à
coeur joie dans leur voiture après
vérification il avait bel et bien rempli
leur attestation de déplacement lui avec
l'indication activité physique elle avec
la mention courses de première nécessité
question de point de vue malheureusement
pour eux ce petit coït leur aura coûté
135 euros chacun enfin un jeune homme en
provenance de lyon et qui devait se
rendre à marseille a été à rester loin
de chez lui un couscoussier sur le siège
passager
lorsque la police lui a demandé pourquoi
il n'était pas chez lui le jeune homme a
répondu que sa maman lui avait préparé
un bon couscous qu'il devait ramener à
la maison un couscous qui lui aura coûté
le prix d'un bol de caviar
foot voilà à dalé alors ça c'est dans
numéro 5 des insolites valérie bénaïm ça
te fait rire ma chérie je suis un bandit
pedro
maintenant moi je suis vraiment vous
connaissez assez intolérante sur le côté
on essaye de d'esquiver que je comprends
que certains aient besoin de sortir mais
vraiment restant à la maison au maximum
alors vraiment très important alors vous
dites on comprend que les gens qui aient
besoin de sortir et y'a un truc qui a
énormément besoin aujourd'hui c'est le
top 4 de nos insolite c'est la
réouverture de plusieurs drive de mac do
u qui a provoqué des kilomètres
d'embouteillage
certains automobilistes ont fait jusqu'à
trois heures de queue pour pouvoir
récupérer un hamburger
c'est complètement fou regarde ça c'est
incroyable regarder ces numéros 15 avec
la fermeture de tous les restaurants
depuis le 15 mars dernier les français
ont repris l'habitude de manger maison
visiblement certains ont dû découvrir
qu'ils n'étaient pas les rois des
fourneaux au vu du phénomène qui s'est
produit hier en région parisienne
en effet les services mcdrive des
mcdonald's de france ont décidé de ré
ouvrir leurs portes pour permettre à
leurs clients de commander à nouveau des
hamburgers sans prendre le risque de
mettre en péril les gestes barrière
c'est donc depuis leur voiture que les
clients viennent chercher leur commande
sans pour autant pouvoir manger sur
place
une réouverture qui visiblement se
faisait attendre si on en croit les
trois heures de bouchons qui se sont
créées pour accéder au mac do nas deux
mois ci en seine-et-marne des centaines
d'automobilistes affamés se sont
précipités vers ce restaurant en
apprenant sa réouverture les images à
peine croyable un tel buzz que sur les
réseaux le hashtag mcdonald's s'est même
retrouvé en top tweets
la firme a décidé de procéder à des
réouvertures mais en protégeant au
maximum ses employés masques gants
obligatoires marquage au sol et
distanciation social de mise
rien n'a été laissé au hasard une chose
est sûre s'il y en a un qui peut avoir
le sourire en ce moment c'est bien
ronald mcdonald
[Musique]
pour voitures écoles with the garden
alors mcdonald's s'est vraiment bien
débrouillé par rapport aux consommateurs
qui en avaient envie il en lumière deux
s'il vous plaît que je vois gilles bien
merci
henry j allais ont ouvert 30 la moitié
en ile de france la moitié dans la
région de tours ils ont pris des mesures
pour le personnel on disait je crois
qu'on ne peut pas payer en espèces et en
fait ils ont fait une ouverture
progressive en bossant en amont tout à
l'heure vous parliez de réouverture de
certains lieux de consommation comme les
restaurants baston que c'est un bon
exemple de ce qu'on peut faire
c'était très attendu et c'est pas mal
fait du tout merci matthieu delormeau
valérie me tue de rien je débute alors
on a fous-rires avec valérie blais mais
au-delà de tout ça c'est dit aussi
quelque chose sur de tous était
amplement genre est exactement comme
l'avait vu à l'époque vous souvenez pour
nutella les gens qui s'étaient jetés
dessus mais région que mcdonald's à la
base ça avait été créé pour père un
hamburger à 1 $ pour les ouvriers à
l'heure de la pause aux états unis ça
reste de la phase coûte pas cher et au
delà du goût il ya aussi beaucoup de
gens qui font aujourd'hui trois heures
la queue pour aller se nourrir parce
qu'ils n'ont plus de revenus
donc c'est symptomatique aussi presse en
ce moment après après mathieu après
mathieu agir et qu'on a tous envie de
notre mcdo c'est n'importe quoi c'est
vrai qu'elle sait les réouvertures sens
comme frère quand et enfin de pessah et
cta qu'une envie aux pizzas
c'est comme un connard aigri frère c'est
comme ça c'est exactement pareil quand
tu es en fin de message de les fixer une
fête juive ou t'as pas le droit de
manger plein de trucs de gueule tu
montres que des galettes mon frère c'est
à dire tu manges une galette mon frère
dan tu sais pas comment la galette le
frère elle fait comme ça tu mange un
morceau de galette comme ça mon frère tu
vas au toit les trois jours tu sais pas
comment allait croiser ou d'un frère
certes oui nous ça s'appelle la mac ça
ça peut vous appeler maître de maison
c'est la mafia c'est la mafia c'est pas
la balade
ça veut dire que le frère ton chez
déroule serviette
non mais c'est un morceau de maths ça
comme la merde tu schiphol en béton non
mais c'est après deux fours non sans
déconner non mais vraiment je dis donc
voilà donc eh ben c'est pareil c'est
pareil de lobito envie de toi un bureau
à paris
penneteau est battu mais c'est vrai que
c'est comme le col ramadan est près de
moi je sais voilà voilà nos yeux d'une
vie des gens me disent tu as envie tu as
envie tu manges rires tu mangeras ainsi
pas n'importe quoi faire quand tu
attends peu plus frère n'a pas mangé
depuis le sait pas combien de 2,2
thunder
moi je moi je mange n'importe quoi mais
là c'est pareil sur les faits toutes les
fêtes religieuses toi mais je fais tout
moi c'est comme à la baisse la pac
si c'est pas mon 9 si j'ai pas mon
enfant chocolat je le trouve pas c'est
sûr c'est partout la femme chocolat à je
fais comment moi je fais comment mais la
page de la fausse et oui ce fait au bon
lait shihri en top 3 des insolites
tiens ça va intéresser leur enseigner et
sophie cost et je veux avoir un
témoignage après à quoi répond nous
pendant le confinement des spécialistes
se sont penchés sur la question ils ont
constaté qu'il ya une recrudescence de
rêves érotiques
on vous explique tout ça c'est en
troisième position je voulais même
benhaim a fait un rêve érotique je vous
jure que c'est vrai elle a rêvé d'une
merguez qui enjambe une boulette
s'il ya bien quelque chose qui manque
pendant le confinement c'est le contact
avec les gens car si certains ont la
chance d'être confiné avec leur moitié
beaucoup sont en famille avec leurs
parents entre amis ou même sol et le
temps commence à être long un manque de
contact social qui a des influences et
pas seulement la journée car cette
période de confinement aurait aussi un
impact sur nos rêves selon plusieurs
psychanalyse de nombreux français qui
liraient davantage de rêves érotiques
durant cette période comme en témoigne
le flora une auditrice de la radio
europe 1 depuis le début du confinement
je remarque que je fais des rêves
érotiques qu'est ce que cela signifie
pour catherine blanc psychanalyste et
psychothérapeute spécialisée en
sexologie tout cela s'explique très bien
d'une façon générale on peut se dire que
c'est une volonté d'embrasser le monde
et de rentrer en lien les uns avec les
autres avec toute sa force et la
sexualité fait par coup de la force de
chacun la psychanalyste et psychologue
clinicienne elisabeth ses reins et
l'historien hervé masurel ont quant à
eux eu l'idée de recueillir les rêves de
plusieurs français confiné pour les
analyser et là encore le verdict est
sans appel les rêves érotiques sont en
pleine recrudescence
une période au moins propice à faire des
rêves plus agréable que des
et ouais et ouais alors est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça sophie cost moi
j'ai assez envie d'embrasser le monde en
ce moment c'est vrai donc ça ne va après
j'ai un sommeil assez agitée j'ai lu pas
mal d'études au dessus des truands fait
sur la sédentarité et j'ai un sommeil il
a fractionné s'est largement d'or je me
réveille deux heures après je fais pas
mal de redd et redd monétique oui quand
même parce que voilà j'espère que ce que
je peux vous poser une question et vous
me répondez dit franchement dit live
est-ce que vous avez déjà rêvé d'une
personne de l'équipe et oui et il faut
nous dire qui c'est d'allumer quoi non
vous savez monsieur mais je consommais
s'explique en fait complètement
autrement on trouve parmi les rêves non
mais je dirais tu sais pas si simple que
ça écoutez je suis pas né de la dernière
pluie n'est pas au vieux singe qu'on
apprend à faire la grimace au pick up
s'il vous plaît
sophie qu est-ce que attendez attendez
je vais demander de faire le petit toit
va nous raconter ce qui s'est passé mon
ami laurent seigne est ce que vous avez
déjà rêvé une personne de l'équipe a un
rêve érotique dit l'amérique
oui tout à fait si à paris la vérité je
vous l'avais déjà dit vous savez que
mange la moire est amoureux des messages
me l'a déjà dit mais sinon vous savez je
suis très amoureuse enfin on passe de
l'équipe la benhaim aussi l arrivée de
2,2 vallat de guillaume guillaume genton
de moi aussi mais moi non mais
maintenant les ballons
ici bernard non ah bah mon avis cette
belle chose ça devait se passer dans une
cabine à uv chanter comme vous allez
nous raconter votre rêve qu'est ce qui
s'est passé là alors on était dans un
fait en étant une barre qui ont des
temps d une rivière et c'était assez
calme au départ j'ai en tête dans mon
rêve
ouais dans une barque est en fait dans
mon rêve alors cette boubou ramier voyez
moi j'étais je vous regarde mais sa
passe est en fait dans mon rêve c'est
très clair gens on était vraiment les
gars ensemble on était à un coup gars
c'est étonnant preuve en est à 1 coupon
100 premiers super bien et tout est un
moment donné il ya eu une espèce de
commun les rapides voiliers et vous avez
perdu
les rames dont vous étiez un peu en
perdition et je vous ai jeté à un gilet
de sauvetage et vous m'avez dit non
m'avait dit non vous êtes levés magazine
on garde le et à ce moment là j'ai
découvert que vous souhaitiez nues quand
même en place et je me suis réveillé à
spa alors je vais vous dire si je vais
vous dire la vérité votre rêve on voit
que c'est un rêve on voit que ça n'est
pas la réalité si j'avais été nul que
j'avais perdu les rames
j'aurais pu autre chose pour américains
auraient arrêté à bon port
merci voilà donc on voit que ce n'est
qu'un rêve aller exactement et je peux
vous dire je vous aurais anne à beauport
sophie koch ne vous inquiétez pas vous
étiez très bien payant en tout cas avec
moi bah merci bonne saveiro revois la
mer on sait que cet arrêt cet arrêt
devrait cependant c'est pas érotique du
tout heureusement dieu soit loué dieu
soit loué les cherry en deuxième
position nos enfants sony du jour c'est
le concours miss france qui est
complètement chamboulé à cause de la
crise du coronavirus regarder ce qui va
se passer pour le concours miss france
alors là moi ça m'a mais ça m'a glacé
leçon j'avais le sont alors essayé
j'avais le sentiment qu'au nom qui me
connaît
bizuth coronavirus oblige chacun
s'adapte comme il peut pour poursuivre
son activité
c'est le cas de nombreux secteurs et le
monde des concours n'échappe pas à la
règle
l'élection miss france se déroule chaque
année autour du mois de décembre mais
avant ça toute l'année les élections de
miss régionales ont lieu dans toute la
france pour désigner les 30 prétendantes
à la couronne des élections qui en
raison du coronavirus ont été dans un
premier temps annulé mais se poursuivent
aujourd'hui en télétravail
en effet s'il n'est pas possible pour
les jurés de voir les miss en vrai
sylvie tellier la présidente du comité a
annoncé que les élections allaient se
dérouler en partie par vidéo les
prétendants devront envoyer trois vidéos
pour se présenter et se montrer des
vidéos de quelques minutes qui
permettront au jury de faire une
première sélection une stratégie pour
éviter l'annulation pure et simple du
prochain concours une annulation qui
n'est plus arrivé depuis longtemps la
seule période où la france n'a pas pu
élire sa reine de beauté
c'était pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale d'autant qu'en 2021 le concours
fêtera son centenaire une date
historique à côté de laquelle sylvie
tellier et ses équipes n'ont pas
l'intention de passer oui oui et sylvie
tellier sûr réjoui de la solution
qu'elle a trouvé la présidente d'emi
france c'est un nouveau mode de
sélection pensée pour les jeunes filles
d'aujourd'hui que j'aime qualifiée de
génération instagram souvent très
aguerris aux outils numériques
bref nous lançons la sélection 2.0
hashtag les mises
j'adore c'est dans le monde j'adore ou
alors qu'elle allait très vite qu'ils
sont en penser parce que je sais c'est
absurde
comment on peut juger les gens par vidéo
alors on partage leurs impôts locaux
regardez vous vous êtes magnifique en
vidéo vous inscrire c'est résume alizés
mieux vaut annulé que faire une mauvaise
sélection comme ça on verra bien la
bande on sait très bien voilà la raison
cette façon de voir les gens ont fait
que ça maintenant on est tous sur les
vidéos les et les comptes déjà eu donc
eu l'idée après l'émission serait plus
compliqué série kadiri excellent
camarade est toujours très très bon en
débat mathieu toujours le pas du tout si
tu veux jouer le jeune alors qu'il n'est
plus écartée c'est l'exemple justement
du mec qui met 19 filtres pour pas faire
50 ans donc je demande s'il ya bien un
endroit on peut plus juger de la beauté
tout ce qui est instagram tout ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui un retard à z ses
résidents touchés
je vous montrerai une photo une fois
deux mois en vacances avant après nam et
c'est hallucinant ce qu'on peut faire
prenons les gens
mais alors si ça bonnaire malzieu et
mathieu mon chéri on n'a pas besoin de
voir la photo dans vacances avant après
bon je peux très bien mettre demain une
image de mou sur le plateau une image
nouveau maintenant les gens comprendront
fait la police c'est une malade donc tu
dois encore pire j'appelle tout va
rentrer dans la police a bien entendu
allez on embrasse les policiers bon
courage quand il va arriver et les
pauvres au top indé insolite je vous dis
aujourd'hui en numéro 1 je sais vous
allez kiffer en première position
on vous a mis les chansons les plus
drôles du confinement puisque chaque
jour il y en a des nouvelles on vous a
préparé une petite sélection
regardez c'est le top indé insolites les
chansons les plus drôles du confinement
et soula il ya bien sûr de notre
inspecteur si le confinement à bien un
avantage c'est qu'il oblige chacun à
trouver des occupations et pousse
certains à créer ou pour occuper le
temps et quand ces mêmes confiné décide
de pousser la chansonnette et de prendre
leurs instruments le résultat est
souvent au rendez vous du moins pour
s'amuser au début du confinement c'est
dj snake qui avait réalisé un tube en
reprenant la voix de la chanteuse car
diby en quelques minutes il avait semblé
son cri pour en faire un titre qui est
déjà un énorme carton sur les réseaux
mais aujourd'hui ce sont des centaines
d'internautes plus ou moins anonymes qui
pousse la chansonnette à l'instar de
juliette et jean-michel et leur appel à
sauver les pattes
bon
les franglaises ont quant à elle opté
pour une version diana qu'amour a
special confinement chénard manquantes
et ne m'emballait j'ai dix conseillers
demandent le duo french vous a décidé
quant à lui de créer une chanson
spéciale pour marteler à tous les gestes
sanitaires une chanson qui pourrait être
diffusé dans les écoles
[Musique]
l'occasion aussi pour elle mme ou de
frises de reprendre son célèbre tube ça
m'énerve et de l'adapter je rêve du
cross est un paris désert sont tous à la
maison
moi aussi j'ai l'air d'un con ça
m'énerve bref autant de chansons qui
risque de nous restée dans la tête pour
un bon moment alors battu de leurs maux
benjamin castadi que ça fait mais je
vous dis des gros fous rires pendant les
sujets on vous expliquera tout âge
[Rires]